[Music]  now let's not creepy at all I want to  play games come here - all you need to  do is confess it sticks out we saw it's  dead is he  jigsaw admitted are in theaters October  27th  ten years ago the games played failure  to make the right choice result in death  what you came back from the dead that's  impossible  jigsaw rated-r in theaters October 27th  the other games simple best ones are you  want to birthday play by the rules  they identification on the victim puzzle  piece but she saw some dead pajamas this  was on the body the truth will set you  free  [Music]  [Music]  the dead man  [Applause]  little guy  you know what happens if we don't follow  the robot the blood under the  fingernails of our victims John Kramer  the jigsaw killer that's impossible  [Music]  [Music]  no that's not creepy at all  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]